there's a lot of people in our studio
who grew up with MORTAL KOMBAT
people remember seeing this crazy arcade
game there's a nostalgia factor that
people connect with we created this
thing that became way bigger than we are
this whole game is a part of my life it
has been for 20 years
it's incredible to actually you know
work on one it's cool seeing the
evolution of the team and the evolution
of the tech this is the moral combat
that people we wanted to do
welcome at excess a lot of different
competitive modes a ton of content for
the player to be able to play we have
story 1v1 rank we have King full
survivor mode test your luck the dynamic
towers are amazing they're going to be
switching some of them on the hour we
want players to feel like they are in
this universe they are seeing the story
evolved with Mortal Kombat Exodus span
of the story it's actually 25 years now
we have a whole new generation of the
characters so that's gonna be really
exciting to see how the fans take that
the story mode in Mortal Kombat X is
just amazing it's is a blockbuster movie
within a game itself I think if we
weren't trying to innovate something
that we wouldn't be motivated adding
something to the game that's never been
done before
we're going to have a much more
aggressive and elaborate online
experience we really wanted to build on
the whole community feeling we're
finally able to globally connect
everyone that plays war combat
first thing you do when you play Mortal
Kombat is pick a faction we have 5
different factions we have black dragon
the Brotherhood of shadow the Lin Kuei
Special Forces and the White Lotus but
with affection mode we want to really
tie that together and give context to it
and give it bigger stakes so everything
you do informs this war the faction war
is a persistent meta game that kind of
builds off of the core game every week
we start a new war and everyone's adding
in every day all the way through the
week and at the end of the week a winner
will be determined based on how many
points and accumulated you're also able
to rank up inside your faction and
unlock customer awards that are that are
specific to the fact that you've joined
everything you do in the game
is contributing to your faction points
so when you play a story mode you're
adding affection points when you play
these towers your and affection points
defeating people from other factions
gives you even more points so it really
kind of encourages the whole competitive
aspect of you know we are a team here
and we are out to defeat other factions
and then for a special 24 hour period
that happens randomly each week the
whole faction system can be invaded by
one of the more powerful realms such as
the nether realm or an outlaw or chaos
rail well I think you're going to be
really excited it's a work
collaboratively with other players as a
team to defeat a common enemy one of the
great things about factions to let
people at very different skill levels or
people who like different modes all
contribute to the war there's something
new every single day that they haven't
seen before since the first time we've
ever done any sort of Cisco kind of
connects everyone together
we keep the heart of the game the same
the combat field we give the player a
lot of new options every Mortal Kombat
game we try to make sure that the fans
and they play it it will be something
they never experienced before
my anxiety would be if we work adding
something we really took the next feed
very seriously with the next gen
technology we could pretty much do
anything we imagined it's the next
generation of the Mortal Kombat universe
Oh